il faudrait attendre l'an 3000 avant
d'avoir la parité la parité au sein du
parlement européen
les femmes sont minoritaires par rapport
à leurs homologues masculins
mais leur nombre a augmenté au fil des
années alors ça c'est super en 1979 les
européens élisent pour la première fois
leurs députés au suffrage universel
direct
les femmes représentent alors 16,6 pour
cent des députés européens
parmi elles la française françoise
gaspard membre du parti socialiste
il pense aux en tant que femme et en
tant que socialiste que le parlement
européen sera effectivement un terrain
de lutte pour les femmes à la fin des
années 80 la féminisation des listes
électorales devient un enjeu pour la
classe politique de 16,6 pour cent en
le pourcentage de femmes députés au
parlement européen a dans les 19 3% lors
des élections de 1989 la société doit
apprendre aussi que les femmes en
attendu attendu attendu que maintenant
le moment est venu qu'elle se manifeste
dans la société
si le nombre de femmes élues au
parlement européen augmente la parité
est encore loin d'être atteint
et en france alors voilà une bonne
question en 1994 le parti socialiste de
michel rocard est l'un des premiers à
proposer une liste de paritaire j'ai pu
voir combien d'une façon générale il
était difficile aux femmes de s'affirmer
et donc dans un deuxième temps j'ai jugé
que la politique des quotas était une
étape indispensable
j'en ai moi même profité en 2000 tous
les partis français et instaure des
quotas
car la loi sur la parité votée
le texte sur la parité pose un principe
autant de candidats que deux candidates
pour les scrutins de liste c'est à dire
les prochaines élections européennes
régionales et municipales
résultat le nombre de françaises et l'ue
augmente leur nombre grimpe à 45% 2004
avant de diminuer légèrement par la
suite de leur côté leurs homologues
européennes sont un peu moins présente
leur nombre stagne entre 1999 et 2004
un chiffre qui remonte pour atteindre 36
1% en 2018
avec la mise en place de quotas par
certains pays dont la pologne
si le nombre de députés française a
considérablement augmenté en 40 ans
la france n'est cependant pas le
meilleur élève européen en 2018
la finlande avec 62% de femmes députés
au parlement suivi du l'irlande et la
croatie la france n'arrive qu'en
huitième position
bon dernier chypre ferme la marche avec
6 7% de femmes élues au parlement
[Musique]